people of the web and people officiali
ny e speak english i fiori all everyone
italiane che cazzo di mi volevo di una
nuova simpatica non so se vi ricordate
cento flores se non ve lo ricordate un
po di alzheimer ce l'avete perché l'ho
fatto in due mesi fa e questo gioco poi
mi vengono a dire che mi vedo sono
ridicoli ma cento floor sarebbe questo
questo giochino per telefono che dove ci
sono 100 piani e tu per superare un
piano devi risolvere un enigma così si
apre la porta e va il piano successivo
ecco che avevo finito tutti e 100 i
livelli di 100 floris però mancano delle
torri speciali che sono la torre alex
fallo conoscerà un amico ecco queste
torri non le ho fatte e non c'è anche il
season tower gli avevo fatto la torre
principale che ho finito tutta sono
stato un fan non so neanche come ho
fatto a finirla tutta che capelli
orrendi che quindi devi partire con la
torre alex lei sloveni in free ci vai
taglia la corda
cade il sasso che non era un sasso si è
rotto l'uovo viva la vita avevo prendono
il volo forse vado a metterci il nido
sopra aspetto che c'è un nido qua non
sono capace cosa devo fare è pittura il
muro o questi oggetti che sono ancora
della partita precedente proprio
prendilo che l'ho preso l'ex dove
partiamo già ricordatevi che c'è nel
caso abbiate visto il gameplay di 100
fossi io faccio un po cagare quindi
vediamo cosa tiro fuori la tiro la leva
a dell'unico sistema devo fare l'orario
forse devo sommare la lora forse
allora quelli in quello sono le che ne
so se devo fare aiuto arma devo mettere
l'orario seguente che pirla questo
sicuro questo è sicuramente così
quest'altro non sono il tipo che si
rischiò devi let's go baby mama mia
stessa vai vai vai che su forte vai
qua c'è la pace ragazzo un fortissimo
[Musica]
paga la mossa cosa e carta forbice sasso
cosa mi significa quindi carta sasso
forbice quindi carta 55 dita sasso 0
forbice 2
la carta dal sasso che il primo 2 giusto
che carta fbc 5 allora ma signori ma mai
stai in pace ma come chi è ma chi l'ha
mai sentito quello quello noi youtuber
propria destra dio devo tenere il ritmo
ho fatto
cariche che musicista rega non so
neanche cosa ho fatto ma va bene next
level ci sono sempre cento quindi come
stiamo messi scaffalature degli host
riesca a fare qualcosa di decente o
ragioniamo puoi mettere un cerchio puoi
mettere una ics cerchio hicks allora
giochiamo a tris ma scusami cosa devo
fare qua fortemente di cose di noi
tattici loro
eccolo no no no no bixby ma che mickey's
rincula bixby torna indietro
ma chi sei tu di conoscere erano a
cascata i libri bene l'acqua c'è una ics
aoc ea dovevo avvicinare gli scaffali o
che va bene la ics più cerchio il
cerchio fa un cerchio di nuovo certo c'è
il cerchio cerchio perfetto perfetto da
me larga next piano kabaka speriamo che
seppur è morta e trascina al dito 1 what
cos'è sta roba
prima di tutti questo un problema tipo
di schiavon il giochino lì ma io sono
sprecato su youtube un fenomeno un dio
un grande unico il sommo sono anche io
cosa ho fatto
va bene con una mossa sala dovrà buttare
tutte giù l'ho fatto senza neanche
pensarci
allora quando c'è il tappeto lo prende
la tua lanciato prendo la torcia allora
non sopra e colorato allora farci una
freccia che non ho ben capito cosa
indica la torcia mi indica io ce n'è
un'altra di torcia quale luce la chiave
presa c'è una freccia che indica in
basso pure io faccio la chiave con la
chi aveva procurato e fino a qua a ok
perfetto la torcia serve a qualcosa
ora in mezzo e così sopra e di affitto
l'abbiamo fatto però non ho capito bene
cosa dovrebbe succedere
forse non lo so ora che non sono capace
dai questo è rosso questa blu genio
genio genio a posto bezzini muro
ok ha mica devo metterli nell'ordine
giusto allora questo così come si chiude
e così è giusto in teoria ma non ci
credo
paolo gara papotto acqua
una volta fatto questo devi solo unirli
che è una cagata
se si unissero non ho capito puoi
cambiare proprio lì sopra e allora
eccolo perfetto devono allinearli tu nel
suo en for the boys o bello questo mi
ricorda l'ambientazione di penombra o di
residenti vol
che faccio devo di deflettere il il raid
che faccio aiuto
devo tagliare i cavi tv dove non solo
fare qua c'è il riflesso da di pro
riflesso come lo tolgo con che io poi ho
spostato qualcosa ma non ho capito a
cosa è servito però lo sposa a questo
loro si sposta in giù in su
ma che me ne fa a ok cosa miracolosa mi
è servito a posso spostare anche questo
sopra però sposa questo qua si sposta a
posso sfruttare è dirlo subito e che ne
so io è sfruttato un un vetrino vetrino
perfetto di suri su ok
devo farlo deflettere su qualcosa di per
forza deflem a riflettere mamma mia che
terminologie a scuola confavi j
perfetto questa non era difficile
ecco questo già se ci sono i numeri non
parla la tua lingua
devo scambiare i cose tipo sudoku
costruiti allora 0 cos'è sta roba devo
mettere io non ho parole per descrivere
me stesso però io creato caso
completamente random non ho fatto niente
l'ho capito neanche cosa stavi di cosa
stai parlando però che pesci per i pesci
pesci sono miei amici si cambia ok
allora il rosso è quello che vale di più
quindi scambia con rosso poi il giallo
il giallo vale più del ci sono proprio
altri pesci di b gli altri colori che
non vedo la madonna il verde vale 10
teoria in teoria così è giusto a meno
che non ci sia un altro giallo nascosto
carega e giusto 10 che vale più di nove
che vale più di
7 che vale più di cinque giusto così
eccolo a cagare chi l'aveva visto giallo
verde blu rosso no ma mi mancava un
pesce sempre una questione di pesce e il
bacio iosca che bella ace e ovviamente
dentro la materia sia c'è un'altra così
profondo da togliere sono colori a ok
che figata no allora questa metto qui in
questa lamento qui la verde no
ok allora la verde lamento quo ed è
giusto questa la metto qua per questo
dovrebbe scomparire in teoria no perché
ci deve essere quell'altra più piccola
sotto giusto dall aspetta che casino che
questo edificio
la piccola pallina la blu bakwa la rossa
ma sopra la verde let's go baby let's go
questa del quiz di cristiano ronaldo lo
fa con che fisica tra l'altro questa
roba non dovevo far cadere cosa lo
utilizzare il telefono che doveva che
devo fare scusami come faccia attività a
ok devo tenere il telefono proprio con
quanta poca fisica ma lo stai dicendo
se sto girando il telefono veramente ok
voi non avete capito niente io meno che
voi però vabbè con queste carina
ah ok qua devo fare qualche aspetta one
morto darci sua così monta giallo è per
forza ii porco demonio un ora per far
star o come non li voglio che si co non
me ne frega una sega dell'ananas call
con gli occhialini girarle bagni volte
faccio un livello così mi girano le
balle perché non capiscono e quindi
smettila per cortesia cos'è cos'è
devo ammettere devo farci stare tutti
per questo questo è semplice non sono
maestro di tetris e vi dico la verità
per si sa mai
[Musica]
per uno per un ora sono stato a
guardarlo non capivo quella del persone
anche ante va bene siamo al ragazzi gli
ultimi due per oggi 19 il 20 poi ci
fermiamo perché il mio cervello si è già
un affettato non so se avete presente no
ragazzi e scola sta roba che sono
epilettico
ma mica neanche crash bandicoot era così
difficile porca manco dark souls
ventesimo e ultimo livello per oggi rega
non mi sembra esageratamente difficile
ho l'ho detto è un buon video si
conclude qui in questo momento comunque
cento floors in generale questo pare in
generale mi piace però ci sono certi
livelli che devi veramente evitarti il
cervello fare così sul cervello e
rimetterlo in testa poi trovi la
soluzione e altri che schiacci quasi a
caso tipo questo non capisco
va bè ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
come se non mi piace anche i vari social
con iniziale sera se le voci di schiavi
noi ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]